- Uh, I woke up at 4:30 this morning.
- I woke up at 4:45.
- Because we are on a mission.
♫ Ooo, hashtag hashbrown huntdown
♫ Hashtag hashbrown huntdown ♫
It's really to find the
best fast food hash-browns.
- The patties.
- Potatoes are an amazing thing.
- Potatoes are almost
as versatile as pigs.
- [Both] Rubric
Crispiness.
- Fluffiness.
- We brought a scale,
so we could weigh 'em.
Overall beauty.
- [Both] "Wow" factor.
Damn that's a fine potato.
- Yea, that's like, that's a sexy nod.
- Yea, a sexy nod.
Oh, here's a thing.
When you break open a hash-brown,
it should steam like in the commercials.
You know?
Like you should break it in
half and steam should erupt.
- Steam test.
Hang a right here, then
take a left down Vine,
We'll be in Santa Monica in no time.
We're here.
The Dunkin' Donuts.
I'm lookin' for some hashbrowns.
- I'm gonna get one order of hash-browns
and two coffees.
- Let's get a top-down
and see how beautif--
- So here's the Dunkin Donuts.
- Are these beautiful?
39 grams, that's incredible!
- Steam test.
- Ready?
- Close-up, yea.
- Is this gonna do it?
Ready? And...
I am gonna say a soft
no on the steam test.
- It's like a salty tongue bath.
- I can't give it too much
crispy or fluffy points,
because they kind of blend together.
- They def--
There's no contrast.
- There's no contrast.
- No contrast.
- No "Wow" factor.
- No "wow" factor
- Absolutely.
It has somethin' special about it.
The thing is they're very eatable.
I could just...
He said get one order.
We maybe shoulda' got two.
- Well we have to eat a lot more potatoes,
I didn't want us to spoil
our goose this early.
- Yea.
- Hit us with a Tater Fact, Linda.
- [Linda] The potato is
about 80 percent water
and 20 percent solids.
- 80 percent water?!
- That seems weird.
- Carl's Jr.
- Watch out for that runner.
This is what we're gonna get.
- Ooo.
- Well, we lost two.
Lost two.
115 grams.
- Steam test, steam test!
- Do you see any?
- I didn't see any but it felt better
than the last time.
A little less artisan.
Not that much fluff though.
- No, it's just really a nice crunch.
This is classic potato
that's been fried in a shape.
- Definitely no "wow" factor.
Ready?
- Yea.
- Oh! That was close though!
- Waste another one.
- Oh! That's my boy.
- Same edibility.
- Yea.
- And also we threw
about ten on the ground.
- [Both] Hashtag Hashbrown Huntdown 2K15.
- I thought we were gonna
throw them in our mouths.
- (chuckles) Oh.
Oh, do you wanna do that?
(laughs)
- Alright, we wasted a couple hashbrowns,
but in the end it's really gonna be ok,
because, I mean, the
seagulls will eat 'em.
- Everybody likes seagulls
at their restaurant.
I gotta be honest,
I'm already feeling a little bit sick.
♫ Oh Burger King, where
dreams can be yours. ♫
- May I get an order of hashbrowns?
She was nice.
All of the fast-food workers
have been nice today.
- Yea, it's morning.
They haven't had their day ruined yet.
- I think these look way shittier
than the Carl's Jr. ones.
- Really?
They look exactly the same.
- 118 grams
- 118.
No.
- (laughs)
Do you think this is ever gonna work?
They are fluffy and they are crispy.
I might even give it
a slight "wow" factor.
Yea, I think they're ugly.
- Catch-ability.
- [Keith] Tastebuds. Flavor buds.
- Flavor buds.
- [Both] Hashtag Hashbrown Huntdown 2K15.
- Goddammit.
- This is not as easy as chicken watch.
- You got coffee on your pants.
- I got coffee on my pants.
♫ Taste buds
♫ We're buds in nice duds
♫ And we're eating the spuds ♫
- [Linda] Potato blossoms
used to be a big hit
in royal fashion.
Potatoes first became fashionable
when Marie Antoinette paraded
through the French countryside
wearing potato blossoms in her hair.
- [Keith] Whoa, where are we Chris?
- I'm at the combination
Pizza Hut and Taco Bell.
- That's where I am too.
And Linda.
- [Keith] Okay.
- [Chris] Okay.
It looks average.
39 grams.
- [Both] Steam! Steam!
- It's not crispy and it's not fluffy.
- It's like gooey.
Wooo big truck!
- Yeah I don't like this.
- No wow factor.
- The wow factor is like,
"Wow, really?"
- Uggh.
- It's probably the ugliest one.
- Taco Bell, I love you but
you're new at this breakfast thing
and it's showing.
- Catchable.
- [Both] Hashtag Hashbrown Huntdown 2K15.
- Flavor buds.
Should be taste buds, but...
Thank you.
- Can't stop it.
- Thank you!
- How mad do you get
when somebody doesn't give you the wave?
- [Both] You gotta give 'em a wave
if they let you in.
♫ You gotta give 'em a wave
♫ Give 'em a wave
♫ Give 'em a wave now ♫
- Thank you.
Just wave at me!
Hey do you guys have hashbrowns?
- No.
- You don't have hashbrowns?
- Alright.
- Yeah how's it going?
- Good how you doin'?
- Keith, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- Hey, Chris.
- Are you guys still doing the chicken...?
- Oh no.
- We're doing Hashbrown Huntdown now.
- Oh Awesome.
- Wanna get in the car and come with us?
- Sure.
- So now Ed's going with
us to Jack-in-the-Box.
- Is this the right way?
- No it was a right.
(laughs)
♫ Havin' fun, havin' fun.
♫ Havin' fun at the Jack-in-the-Box. ♫
Oooh.
It's pretty fat brown.
- 50 grams.
- Ooh, what a steam test.
- Ooh it smells really hot.
- I like the fact that the
outsides are nice and crunchy
and then when you feel
the potato in your mouth,
it feels nice and soft, smooth.
- He's better at this than us.
- Yeah.
What do you think? Wow factor?
- Yeah I enjoyed it.
- Damn.
- That's a fine potato.
- Wow.
The first one came out really nice.
The other two kind of
failed on that department.
- So there was a clear,
better-looking system.
- Yes.
- Everything's fine.
- [All] Hashtag Hashbrown Huntdown 2K15.
- What a treat.
- Yeah that was really great.
- Bye.
- The average American
eats about 124 pounds of potatoes per year
while Germans eat about twice as much.
- Remember that that's 80% water
so you're really just staying hydrated.
We're finally going to McDonald's.
- So we made it to our final
destination, McDonald's,
and you know what's right next door.
- We have 20 minutes.
- Let's go get some recruits.
- [Chris] We're all gonna
hashbrowns right now.
- [Keith] Hashbrowns.
We're getting hashbrowns right now.
- Ned come on!
- Let's go, let's go.
- Let's go, we're going to McDonald's.
- Let's go!
This is important it's for a video.
- Come! Hashbrowns!
We're all getting hashbrowns.
Every one of us.
- 50. Let's get an even 50.
Hi, can I get 50 hashbrowns?
- Me and Keith tweeted
that we wanna get hashbrowns with people.
Caya was like, "I'll be there."
Yeah!
- It's a dream come true!
Grab a bag, take a brown, pass it down!
- Hashbrown Huntdown!
- Take a brown, pass it around!
- There it is!
58 grams.
- Wow.
- 58 grams everybody!
(cheering)
- It's fine, everything's fine.
- Perfect crunch, perfect fluff.
- Naturally beautiful.
- Umm it's like the best hasbrowns ever.
- Yeah.
- Every time it gets the wow factor.
- [All] Damn that's a fine potato!
- What a special day we've
had as the taste buds,
but we're gonna sign off with our classic
Hashtag Hashbrown Huntdown 2K15!
(cheering)
- We'll see you next time!
- [Chris] We live in a fast town,
cruising around, eating hashbrowns.
Going to Chik-Fil-A or
McDonald's, Burger King.
What you say?
Jack-in-the-Box, you goin' Subway?
I don't think they have those, not today.
Not tomorrow, not the week later.
No, they don't serve taters.
- Oooooh shit!